ich habe eben von einem wechselbad der
gefühle gesprochen
und das heißt dass zu dem gesamten bild
auf der anderen seite eben leider auch
gehört dass die seit dem 2 november
gelten in kontakt beschränkungen zwar
das dramatische exponentielle wachstum
der neuinfektionen der wochen stoppen
konnten
aber die trendumkehr ausgeblieben ist
wir freuen uns wir freuen uns wenn dir
einen menschen haben die bei uns den pcr
test entwickelt haben und denn die
wissenschaftler uns dann etwas sagen
dann fangen wir an zu sagen denn ja
könnte sein und kann auch nicht sein ich
kann nur sagen nehmen wir das erste
studium entschieden
das hätte ich in der alten
bundesrepublik wahrscheinlich nicht
getan weil ich ganz sicher war dass man
vieles außer kraft setzen kann
aber die schwerkraft nicht die
lichtgeschwindigkeit nicht und andere
fakten nicht und das wird auch weiter
gelten
und deshalb sind die empfehlung meiner
meinung nach richtig geschäfte dann zu
schließen und so hart das ist und ich
weiß wie viel liebe dahinter steckt wenn
bücher in stände aufgebaut werden denn
waffelbäckerei aufgebaut werden es
verträgt sich nicht mit der mit dem
vereinbarung dass wir zum beispiel essen
und verzehren nur zum mitnehmen nach
hause wirklich veränderungen
es tut mir leid aber es ist mir wirklich
am herzen lag
aber wenn wir dafür den preis zahlen
dass wir todeszahlen von tag am tag 590
menschen haben dann ist das nicht
akzeptabel aus meiner sicht deshalb
müssen wir das und welche wissenschaft
und geradezu anfleht vor weihnachten
bevor man oma und opa großeltern und
ältere menschen sieht eine woche der
kontakt reduzierung zu ermöglichen
dann sollten wir vielleicht doch noch
mal nachdenken ob wir nicht irgendeinen
weg finden die ferien nicht erst am 19
beginnt zu lassen sondern vielleicht
schon am 16 was wird man dann im
rückblick auf ein jahrhundertereignis
mal sagen wenn wir nicht in der lage
waren für diese drei tage noch
irgendeine lösung zu sehen und das mag
ja sein
ich mag ja sein dass die aufregung er
schließlich das falsche ist dann muss es
der digital unterricht oder sonstwas
seit ich weiß es nicht das ist auch
nicht meine kompetenz da will ich mich
einmischen
ich will immer sagen denn wir jetzt vor
weihnachten zu viele kontakte und
anschließend ist das letzte weihnacht
mit den großeltern war dann werden wir
etwas versäumt ob das sollten wir nicht
tun
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren